he spoke everyone we see of the
feeling of meaninglessness and the question
is there a connection with the
standard of living
yes insofar as people
do not only start asking about the meaning of life
in situations of extreme need but also
in the opposite case, namely where
all their primitive needs are
fulfilled satisfied just
then in a prosperous society
or a welfare state then
this inner emptiness sometimes breaks open and the
person concerned asks himself why all this
people what is all this external happiness for
i would like to know what it is one can
formulate at the extremes lead to
illnesses or can
extreme hardship but also the
satisfaction of right but only
insofar as one also takes into account
that in and of itself the
feeling of meaninglessness no illness is not a new
rose or not at all certain but it
can lead to it but it can lead to
barbara wagner in  Freistadt work
street 13  ask here as a layman you can also
help fellow human beings according to your method
the layperson can also help his fellow human beings in the process of finding
meaning
but one must not forget that
sometimes a crisis of meaning and value is the
external sign of something that is
actually behind it and that can be
very  a neurosis may even be a psychosis under certain circumstances
so such a person must
first be able to get a
diagnosis there is no therapy without
a previous diagnosis and this
diagnosis can actually only be made by a
specialist but if it
turns out that it is
not a pathological
finding  then of course everyone can do a
lot more for their fellow human beings, even as a layman,
there is even
help myself i know
hundreds of people
who have been helped by reading a book on this
subject just over with the
crisis of meaning the awareness of the problem
is already a help
really the awareness of the problem above all
Last but not least, the feeling of a certain
solidarity, that this feeling of senselessness,
this crisis of meaning, actually
connects you with the best examples of
humanity, because such people
manifest intellectual
honesty and sincerity by
not simply accepting something from the hands of tradition
in response
, but rather themselves and
independently  wanting to struggle
for this also raises the question for wagner in the free state of
whether there is an area
in the human being that one
feels particularly
understood, i.e. the question of
human contact where
human contact is
established, the question of meaning here is not explicit
but implicit  that is, as
the poem said, if a person
feels lovingly bound or lovingly has
the feeling of
belonging to another, then the epz ii
is
already solved in a certain sense by this fact the seven questions
because lie  be is her an aspect possible
are fit i think that gives part of
the answers adolf
matitschka bitter as in 57
brunnengasse 36 at home armani comes
here to the statements about that
there are three things that have to be considered essential to the meaning of
life
firstly, that man is a biological
being for whom it is enough to satisfy his instincts
and thinks it is life
that makes sense but
you accept this statement anja you there i would like to
register a few reservations
insofar as in my opinion the nature
of the  being human means that it
always points beyond itself to
something that is not itself again, i.e.
to a cause in the service of which
man gives up or points to
a person to a partner who you
win when a group is not the
people you love  team
is given, in other words, a person is only
fully human there where he
forgets himself and overlooks u  nd disregards
in the service of a cause or in
the love of a person if but if
that is the case then he is not only
fully human and then also becomes happy
and that unintentionally unintentionally quite
automatically and the reverse
then takes place if one after
I'm lucky that I tend to my constant, so to speak, the
sea is about the lust is about you
more of gcm also that you see most
clearly alms
the more a male patient tries
to demonstrate his potency, the
greater the likelihood that
he will develop impotence  is doomed and
vice versa the more a female
patient cares why she
is now capable of a full orgasm
, the greater the chances are that she will end
with fragility i think that
was the answer to the question 2 3 martin
can this was about the
finding that it is a
social being in human hands word in
which a part of the meaning in the
g  mutual help or seeing is
thematic in its triad here
then the determination as a
psychological being man has the
possibility to use the gifts of nature and
the achievements of culture
and sees as if they are
individuals the fulfillment of the longing
for joy yes but  free because joy
is the effect of self-devotion to
people or to things and if you
now make it your goal you
can nowhere find it more beautifully expressed
than in a poem by gore the
indian
poet and philosopher who says i
slept and dreamed life would be
joy
i woke up and saw life was a
duty i worked and it was a
duty joy now
read yes why so frankl we have
now the last to see
as the last sender gerhard brown probably
at home in Groß harras in lower austria
i had to  so
give it back in an abbreviated version, the
examiner will guess so long  it
's about the question to what extent
religion, which has largely
conveyed meaning and
purpose to people, has now created a vacuum for many people through the loss
and how far
people are
perhaps influenced by this loss in their songs
crises today  that is certainly
correct and there is a word that was
coined by a german psychiatrist
namely the emigration of
occidental humanity from pastoral
care to neurologists this problem has to be faced today by the or
psychotherapist of course
you must not forget every age has
its neurosis and  every age needs its
psychotherapy and today
psychotherapy has to turn to those
states that at the time of sigmund
freud and alfred adler hardly existed,
precisely this feeling of
meaninglessness, this task today falls to the doctor or
the psychotherapist and within
this division to the logo therapist in
one  significant extent in this respect  n
as logotherapy has a specific
indication area, it is also
specifically indicated in those
neuroses that I have described as only gene
neuroses that can be
traced back to
this senseless feeling as soon as this senseless
feeling manifests itself as clinical symptoms
, then logotherapy
is indicated but they  must not
forget, according to international
consensus
estimates that are independent of each other, the percentage of such
lies and roses today is an average of
20 percent,
professor franke,
at the moment, despite the oil crisis, we are still
developing more into a
prosperous society towards a
society that owns
technical and other
good that more and more
have written on their flags do you
mean that we are
also developing down into an abyss
insofar as today's society by
and large d  the aim is to satisfy
practically all
human needs yes some needs are
even consciously generated only one
need comes up empty
that is the most human of all
human needs that is the
need for meaning
that is the will to oneself that to a
care and if
if psychotherapy or
psychology in general in your motivation trainer
does not recognize in time that the human being is
basically a being in search of meaning
, then of course he will not only be
sexually frustrated as before, but now
the train will also be existentially
frustrated and progress will remain and the
The consequence is the increasing
number of suicides in all countries that
have brought prosperity or
welfare since Frankel again